[Music]
the marvel cinematic universe has been
going strong since 2008 but its story at
this point covers thousands of years
need to catch up on the latest
developments ah let's just go through
the whole thing uh where to start um
[Music]
if you really want to know where things
started in the marvel cinematic universe
you have to go all the way back to
before the big bang
no really before the beginning of the
universe before even the creation of the
six singularities that caused the
universe to explode into existence they
were the celestials beings of infinite
cosmic power the celestials led by
arashim the judge created the original
planets stars and life forms of the
infant universe following the big bang
realizing they need help to expand the
universe and create more life the first
celestials seed planets with embryonic
celestials these new gods would be born
once sentient life on each planet rose
to a critical juncture allowing for the
emergence of a new celestial and
resulting in the destruction of that
world to assist in this process the
celestials genetically engineered
deviant monsters to wipe out the apex
predators of each world encouraging
sentient life to develop and multiply
unfortunately the celestials
miscalculated the deviants did their job
so well they started hunting down and
killing all life-forms preventing
emergences to keep them in check the
celestials created the eternals
synthetic life forms sent to different
worlds across the cosmos to kill the
deviants and protect the planet's life
forms regarded as gods and superheroes
by the populace the eternals are
unknowingly preparing the planets for
their destruction following each
emergence the eternal's memories are
wiped so they could be reused on
different worlds meanwhile other
interesting things are happening
throughout the universe the six
singularities that created the cosmos
became the infinity stones objects that
controlled fundamental forces like time
space and reality itself they were then
scattered across the universe popping up
here and there and awaiting the eventual
arrival of a giant golden oven myth that
would be used by a purple sociopath to
kill off half the universe that of
course was billions of years ago but
it's not the only thing to happen in
those long eons millions of years before
we get to the present day mcu ego the
living planet comes into existence gains
cosmic awareness and seeds thousands of
worlds with his essence in an attempt to
create another celestial being like
himself but though he may in fact be a
god-like figure in the end he's still
essentially just a selfish deadbeat dad
no wonder peter has issues well of
course i have issues
that's my freaking father
as far as heroes and villains of earth
are concerned the mcu doesn't start with
tony stark getting kidnapped in 2008
carol danvers being taken to hala in the
90s or even with steve rogers
volunteering for the super soldier
program in the 40s the actual beginning
happened in 5000 bc when 10 immortal
eternals cersei icarus ajac kingo sprite
fastos makari fina jurig and gilgamesh
arrived on earth to take out the
deviants on our planet for thousands of
years the eternals protected emerging
humankind largely through epic super
battles with giant monsters by 1521 the
eternals finally managed to defeat all
the deviants on earth or so they think
lacking any real direction now that
their main reason for coming to the
planet is gone they scatter and get jobs
as teachers bollywood film stars and
south american cult leaders since the
celestials have instructed the eternals
not to interfere in humanity unless
deviants were involved other god-like
beings get the chance to descend onto
earth and have their time to shine these
include the asgardians vastly powerful
alien beings who visit our planet many
times and give rise to norse mythology
still the most exciting stuff those guys
were up to happens off-world in the
realm of asgard this mythological time
scale begins millennia ago as we find
out in thor the dark world when malakath
the accursed lays siege to asgard and is
fought off by bor the father of odin
four vanquishes malakath which turns out
to be a temporary solution while we
don't know exactly when it happens the
next chronological event that we see
from our characters is odin's conquest
of the nine realms alongside his first
child hella goddess of death during this
era the magic warhammer mjolnir is
forged in the heart of a dying star and
used by hela thanks to her bloodthirsty
ruthlessness and ambition odin turns
against her and in the battle that
follows hella slaughters the valkyrior
the sole surviving valkyrie flees from
asgard spending the next few thousand
years drunk and depressed eventually she
winds up on zakar a cosmic garbage dump
that an immortal being called the grand
master builds into an interstellar
gladiatorial arena hella is then
imprisoned in another dimension by odin
who covers up all traces of her
existence
sometime after that but still far enough
back that people were writing about it
in the 13th century odin and frigga have
a son thor shortly thereafter odin slays
the frost giant laughing and adopts his
son loki as his own not too long after
this during their youth loki turns into
a snake because he knows thor loves
snakes and then tries to stab him in one
universe he manages to succeed what was
your nexus event your majesty
i killed the ball
also millions of years before the
present day a meteorite made of the
super metal vibranium strikes earth and
africa drastically affecting the
surrounding area much much later this
area becomes the country of wakanda when
a warrior shaman receives a vision from
the goddess best and founds a dynasty of
kings known as the black panthers the
wakandans become secretive and
isolationist remaining unconquered
throughout history and using the
vibranium to create fantastic technology
away from the eyes of the outside world
moving to just about a thousand years
before the present day the warlord shu
winwoo makes a fantastic discovery of
his own when he comes across 10 other
worldly rings that grant him immortality
and the strength of a god
using the rings to establish his 10
rings criminal organization win woo
conquers kingdoms and topples
governments amassing an incredible power
structure that influences the direction
of the world
believe it or not there's not a whole
lot that happens between the unification
of wakanda the rise of wenwu and the
20th century in 1693 the witch agatha
harkness escapes being burned at the
stake by her mother and a bunch of other
witches who aren't happy with her
practice of dark magic she drains their
life energies and gets her hands on the
dark hold before disappearing to get
into all sorts of trouble before she
pops up again in the present day
jumping ahead to 1942 a nazi officer
known as johann schmidt experiments on
himself with an early version of dr
abraham erskine's super soldier serum
gaining both a physically perfect body
and a decidedly redder complexion now
calling himself the red skull he takes
charge of a splinter group called a
hydra with the discovery of one of the
infinity stones in the form of the
tesseract he creates a technologically
advanced army of his own that same year
steve rogers volunteers for the
strategic scientific reserves attempt at
creating a super soldier using a
technique created by dr abraham erskine
the project works giving steve the body
of a hunky chris evans
after the experiment erskine is
assassinated and his research is lost
rather than risking their only super
soldier by sending him to fight in the
war the ssr gives steve the code name
captain america and uses him primarily
as a spokesman to sell war bonds and uso
shows set to an extremely catchy song
eventually steve goes awol to rescue his
best friend bucky barnes and becomes an
active soldier in the war leading a
strike team called the howling commandos
including bucky on one of their missions
bucky falls from a train into a ravine
seemingly to his death however bucky is
actually taken into custody by the
soviet army given cybernetic
enhancements and brainwashed into
becoming a super assassin codenamed
winter soldier after attempting to use
the tesseract the red skull is sucked
into a wormhole becoming the second
person in captain america the first
avenger to survive an apparent death in
reality he winds up on the distant
planet vormir serving as a sort of
spectral guardian for the soul stone as
for steve he crashes a bomber jet into
the arctic to keep hydra from destroying
new york he is also presumed dead but he
survives frozen in suspended animation
for the next 66 years geez doesn't
anyone who dies in this movie actually
die
while things are pretty quiet for the
mcu between 1945 and 1995 there are a
few notable exceptions peggy carter
continues to work for the ssr first in
new york in 1946 and then in los angeles
alongside howard stark in 1947 around
this time the soviet union produces the
first graduates of its brutal red room
facility where orphaned girls are
trained as spies and assassins
black widows some time after this
presumably around 1948 or 49 steve
rogers travels back in time from 2023 to
reunite with peggy she continues to work
in military intelligence for the next
few decades with stark whose defense
contracts turned stark industries into
the world's leading arms manufacturer by
1970 both of them are working out of ssr
headquarters at camp lehigh along with a
few other notable figures arnhem zola
who worked with the red skull back in
the 40s is stationed here and although
his body dies in the 70s his brain is
transferred into a computer data bank
that continues hydra's infiltration of
the government also hank pym is working
here assisted by bill foster in his
experiments with the size-changing pym
particles that will allow him and his
wife janet van dyne to become the
original ant-man and wasp
between the 70s and the 90s several
small but key events happen throughout
the mcu in 1974 howard stark launches
the stark expo displaying the city of
the future powered by a clean energy arc
reactor that's about the size of a house
for some reason he also hides the
structure of a new element in the
arrangement of the buildings which is
the kind of science it pays to not think
too hard about congratulations
you have created a new element in 1980
ego comes to earth winning the heart of
meredith quill nine months later their
son peter quill is born in 1987 janet
van dyne is lost in the quantum realm
after she and hank pym attempt to stop a
rogue soviet missile targeting the
united states in 1988 meredith quill
dies from brain cancer intentionally
caused by ego leaving her son a mixtape
of classic rock favorites peter is then
abducted by a band of outer space
outlaws called the ravagers their leader
yondu then raises quill as a son albeit
very abusively in 1989 pym resigns from
the ssr now renamed the strategic
homeland intervention enforcement and
logistics division after finding out
that they intended to use pym particles
to create weapons also that year air
force captain carol danvers who uses the
callsign avenger during her flights
volunteers for a test flight of a
lightspeed engine created by scientist
wendy lawson lawson turns out to be one
of the cree a militaristic alien race
constantly at war with the
shape-shifting scrawls and her engine is
powered by the tesseract when they're
shot down carol's body is overloaded
with the tesseract's energy giving her
incredible powers and also wiping her
memory a cree soldier named ian rog
abducts her and takes her back to the
cree homeworld of hala where she is made
to believe that she's actually a cree
named viers fighting alongside them as a
member of the kree star force
while all of this is happening on earth
things continue to develop in space
thanos an incredibly powerful alien from
the planet titan who's obsessed with
balance begins to seek out the infinity
stones along the way he lays ways to
half of the population of entire planets
occasionally taking young survivors and
training them as soldiers assuming that
most of the more humanoid characters are
the same age as the people portraying
them then his two most notable adoptions
happen in the late 80s or early 90s
gamora is taken in as a young girl after
thanos kills half of the population of
her home planet
throughout her childhood thanos pits her
against her adopted sister nebula every
time they spar gamora wins and thanos
systematically replaces pieces of
nebula's body with cybernetic parts in
order to make her a more efficient
killer this creates a lot of resentment
in nebula not only against thanos but
also toward gamora which will greatly
affect their later relationship
in 1991 the soviet government sends the
winter soldier to assassinate howard and
maria stark this will have massive
ramifications later on but the immediate
effect is that their brilliant slacker
son tony stark is left in charge of
stark industries along with obadiah
stain as ceo they continue to
manufacture weapons using tony's
increasingly deadly designs
selling them to all sides of virtually
every global conflict with obadiah in
particular making a profit from secret
arms deals with terrorist groups
in 1992 king tachaka of wakanda goes to
oakland california to investigate arms
deals involving stolen vibranium the
culprit is his brother in jobu who is
killed in the altercation in jobu's son
eric is a witness to the whole thing and
grows up craving revenge
meanwhile russian super soldier alexi
shostakov and black widow weapons
designer molina vostikov go deep
undercover in ohio posing as an
all-american family with their so-called
daughters seven-year-old natasha romanov
and three-year-old elena bilova while
alexi and molina work to steal a shield
or actually hydra project focused on
free will and mind control natasha and
elena experience some semblance of a
normal childhood by 1995 however the
mission is complete and the family flees
to cuba however once they arrive they
are split apart and natasha and elena
return to the red room where they
continue their black widow training
slash torture sessions
also in 1995 carol danvers still without
her memories of earth returns to her
home planet after escaping from the
skrulls she teams up with shield agents
nick fury and phil coulson to stop the
skrulls from invading earth only to
learn that they're not actually the bad
guys instead it's the cree that are the
problem with janrog and ronan the
accuser enroute in search of the
infinity stones that will end their war
of conquest once and for all
carol taking the name captain marvel
fights them off and saves a bunch of
skrull refugees in the process an alien
cat scratches nick fury's left eye
blinding it and causing him to sport a
fashionable eye patch for the rest of
the series before she journeys back into
space to aid the skrulls carol gives
fury a pager that can summon her in case
of a dire emergency inspired by carol
and her original call sign fury lays the
groundwork for the avengers initiative a
program designed to create a team of
super powered heroes to deal with
large-scale threats like alien invasions
in 1996 win woo having used his ten
rings organization to secretly conquer
or influence practically everything on
earth turns his attention to the
mystical realm of talo after finding a
magical forest near the village entrance
he meets and falls in love with the
village guardian ying li
the two marry and have two children
changji and xiao ling for a time win
will reforms but when his wife is killed
by his rivals he decides to recreate the
ten rings and train his son chongqi to
be a living weapon in 1999 tony stark
meets bioengineers maya henson and
aldridge killian at a conference in
burns switzerland he's very rude to
aldrich who remembers that as a sore
point for about 14 years
throughout all this hydra continues its
secret infiltration of shield and all
levels of the united states government
all that brings us to 2008 and iron man
the movie that launched the mcu almost
everything from here on plays out in
chronological order in the years the
movies were actually released almost in
2008 tony stark is demonstrating his
newest weapons in the middle east when
he's kidnapped by a terrorist
organization called the ten rings in
what will eventually be revealed as a
plot by stain to get tony out of the
picture while he's imprisoned the
terrorists forced him and another
captive dr ho yinsen who was also at
that fateful 1999 convention in burn not
that tony noticed to make weapons for
them instead tony is able to recreate a
miniaturized version of his father's arc
reactor using it to stabilize a piece of
shrapnel that's lodged near his heart
the reactor also powers the iron man a
suit of weaponized armor built from
scrap which allows tony to escape after
jensen's death tony stark was able to
build this in a cave
with a box of scraps
he returns to america eats a
cheeseburger refines his design and
wipes out the ten rings the ones in the
middle east at least in a brutally
effective display of the iron man's
weapons he also defeats stain who
attempts to kill tony and create his own
massive suit of powered armor tony then
publicly reveals his identity as iron
man causing nick fury to approach him
about the avengers initiative around the
same time as tony's capture dr bruce
banner whose seven bhds apparently
include physics and biological
engineering is working on recreating the
super soldier program instead of
erskine's vita rays he uses gamma
radiation testing it on himself and
turning himself into a rampaging green
monstrous hulk whenever he gets angry
after the hulk inadvertently injures
banner's girlfriend betty ross he
attempts to go underground but returns
to america in search of a cure for his
condition he winds up dealing with a
scientist named samuel stearns who wants
to recreate the hulk and a soldier
called emil blonsky who turns himself
into a similarly hulking monster called
the abomination also around this time
shield agent clint barton aka hawkeye is
tasked with finding and eliminating
natasha romanov the black widow barton
tracks down natasha to her safe house in
budapest but feels natasha wants out of
the red room so he lets her live shield
decides to let natasha defect to their
side but requires her to kill her
overseer general drakov first natasha
and clint rig a five-story building with
bombs and lure the red room's mastermind
into the kill zone but dracop's young
daughter antonia also gets caught in the
explosion while disturbed by the
additional red in her ledger natasha
nevertheless begins working for shield
six months after revealing his identity
publicly tony stark is called to testify
before congress because they are
justifiably concerned about a private
citizen building a suit of armor that
can vaporize a tank to create their own
version they turn to rival weapons
manufacturer justin hammer after tony's
friend colonel james rhodes delivers a
prototype iron man suit hammer and
russian scientist ivan venko reverse
engineer them into an army of drones
stark also gets a new personal assistant
who is revealed to be shield agent and
red room defector natasha romanov the
black widow i want one no stark and
rhodes equipped with his own militarized
suit of armor codenamed war machine
defeat bonko and hammer over at the ten
rings compound a now 14 year old chongqi
has become the master of kung fu having
been taught every possible way to kill a
man over the last seven years assigned
to assassinate the man responsible for
his mother's murder chiang chi completes
his mission but is badly traumatized
unwilling to return to his father chiang
chi cleverly adopts the name sean and
starts going to high school in san
francisco there he meets his best friend
katie a skilled driver while all this is
happening on earth there's other stuff
going on in the golden realm of asgard
loki tricks thor into antagonizing the
frost giants of jotenheim against odin's
orders as a consequence odin exiles thor
to earth and enchants his hammer mjolnir
so that only someone worthy of thor's
power can lift it it lands in new mexico
where agent coulson discovers it after a
bunch of hicks try to yank it out of the
ground with pickup trucks shield
constructs a temporary facility around
it thor eventually proves himself worthy
regains his hammer and stops loki from
staging a coup in asgard in 2011 a team
of russian oil drillers discovers the
crashed hydra plane and the arctic and
alerts shield
captain america is thought out and
revived and after realizing he's in the
21st century he joins up with nick
fury's avengers initiative it turns out
he was just in time
in 2012 loki last seen a drift in space
after his failed coup in asgard is
enlisted by thanos to recover the
tesseract from earth with his recent
brief visit to the planet being seen by
the mad titan as relevant employment
experience in exchange thanos gives him
control of the chitauri a massive army
of hive-minded destroyers which would
allow loki to lay waste to the planet
loki apparently being in one of his
moods that day agrees he lets himself be
captured by shield incites a riot and
stabs poor phil coulson in the back but
don't worry he gets better the ensuing
ruckus provides the superheroes with a
reason to come together the result is
the battle of new york in which the
avengers captain america iron man thor
black widow hulk and hawkeye are
gathered for the first time as a team
the good guys win after loki is smashed
against the ground five or six times but
the battle is not without its
consequences unlike in the real world
where it's pretty nice these days the
mcu's version of hell's kitchen takes a
lot of damage and winds up being a
center of corruption and graft as it's
rebuilt this injustice leads blind
lawyer matt murdock to take on the
identity of daredevil to fight against
criminal kingpin wilson fisk and
eventually team up with other
super-powered street-level crime
fighters jessica jones luke cage iron
fist and kinda sword of the punisher on
netflix
the reconstruction of new york is mostly
handled by the newly formed department
of damage control who take over the
lucrative contract and leave
construction foreman adrian tombs
embittered and in possession of advanced
alien technology while the battle of new
york comes with its fair share of trauma
it also leaves some people inspired
after seeing clint barton unknowingly
saving her life while battling aliens
with a bow and arrow ten-year-old kate
bishop decides to take up archery and
learn martial arts in an attempt to
protect her family against future
threats she turns out to be a gifted if
extremely reckless prodigy who often
damages public property with their trick
shots in 2013 tony stark in particular
is overwhelmed by the concept of his
universe suddenly expanding to include
gods aliens and other unknowable cosmic
forces he deals with post-traumatic
stress which unfortunately coincides
with the return of aldrich killian
kilian has been experimenting with maya
hansen's regenerative extremist
treatment which has the unfortunate
tendency to cause its subjects to
explode
to cover his operations kilian
appropriates win woo's tin rings and
creates a fictional terrorist based on
win woo called the mandarin hiring an
actor named trevor slattery to play him
in threatening videos the plot is
uncovered and stopped by tony and rhody
i wouldn't go in there for 20 minutes
in the aftermath killian is killed by
pepper potts and slattery gets sent to
federal prison where he's later abducted
by the real tin rings for impersonating
winwoo although winwoo is intent on
killing this strange man who named
himself after a chicken dish he has a
change of heart after seeing how good
slattery is at performing shakespeare
and decides to make him his jester
around this time phil coulson resurfaces
and begins recruiting some additional
members into his own agents of shield
they have their own adventures including
many involving the inhumans and ghost
rider but like the good secret agents
they are a lot of this flies beneath the
radar of most major mcu events
oh also malekith comes back and thor
fights him and loki becomes the latest
in a long line of presumed deaths that
actually aren't he stashes odin in a
retirement home in new york and then
takes his identity ruling over asgard
and putting on critically acclaimed
plays i'm sorry about that thing with
the tesseract i just couldn't help
myself i know i'm a trickster
in 2014 hydra's decades-long plot to
infiltrate and take over america is
finally discovered by captain america
and black widow who also learned that
the winter soldier is a brainwashed
bucky barnes while cap fights to restore
his best friend's memories the hydra
plot is exposed and in the aftermath
shield collapses leaving the avengers
without the oversight and support of the
larger organization that power vacuum
leads directly to tony stark and bruce
banner attempting to create an
artificial intelligence that would help
protect the world unfortunately they
goof that plan up big time instead
creating a genocidal robot named ultron
who winds up destroying an entire city
resulting in the breakup of the country
sokovia hoping for an ally against
ultron tony and bruce combined the mine
stone a synthesized body created by
ultron and tony's onboard ai jarvis into
a much more heroic ai called the vision
also scarlet witch and quicksilver two
definitely not mutants join the team
speedster quicksilver immediately dies
partly from bullets but mostly because
disney and fox were having a problem
figuring out the character's film rights
the destruction in sokovia also kills
the family of helmut zemo who then
dedicates his life to revenge
immediately after the battle the hulk
hijacks a quinjet and blasts off to
space eventually landing on zakar while
all that's going on peter quill is out
in space on a job to steal a valuable
orb which unbeknownst to him contains an
infinity stone that puts him in the
sights of both ronin the accuser who's
been looking for another infinity stone
since 1995 and thanos who sends gamora
after him quill and gamora wind up
running across drax a very literal
warrior whose family was killed by
thanos rocket a space raccoon who was
painfully experimented on and given
cybernetic enhancements and groot a tree
after being in prison together the five
of them stage at jailbreak defeat ronin
in the dance-off recover the power stone
with the help of the real power which is
friendship and turn it over to the
novacore a bunch of space cops on the
planet xandar
shortly thereafter thanos attacks zandar
and recovers it for himself
in 2015 an electrical engineer named
scott lang gets out of prison and
stumbles on to hank pym's old size
changing equipment under the guidance of
pym and his daughter hope lang becomes
the second ant-man and helps to keep the
pym particles from falling into the
hands of an evil arms dealer more
importantly it's likely somewhere around
this time that a kid named peter parker
is bitten by a radioactive spider tries
to capitalize on his powers by becoming
famous as spider-man and fails to stop a
robber that later kills his uncle ben
none of this is actually covered in the
mcu but you might have seen five other
movies about it the following year sees
helmut zemo's plan to destroy the
avengers reach its fruition as the world
responds to the destruction of sokovia
by trying to install new governmental
oversight over the avengers zemo
furthers a wedge between captain america
and iron man by revealing that bucky was
the one who killed tony stark's parents
he also frames bucky for the
assassination of king tachaka of wakanda
leaving the king's son t'challa to take
over leadership of the country not to
mention the identity and powers of the
black panther the end result of all of
this is that the avengers break up the
ones loyal to cap go underground and
t'challa refuses to give zemo the death
he desires fleeing the us after the rest
of cap's team is imprisoned natasha
romanov spends some time in norway
watching james bond films unfortunately
her vacation is cut short when she's
attacked by taskmaster an assassin who
can mimic any fighting style later she
discovers taskmaster is the brainwashed
daughter of a still alive general drakov
who has restarted a crueler version of
the red room that brainwashes new black
widows and robs them of free will one of
those black widows turns out to be
natasha's sister elena freed of her
programming by another widow yelena
sends the brainwashing antidote to
natasha drawing her into the fight
together elena and natasha work to
reunite with her former parents alexi
and molina and really kill drakoff this
time although the dysfunctional deep
cover family has more than its share of
issues they manage to pull together and
take down the red room in the end elena
gets to work liberating black widows
around the world while natasha goes to
break her other family the avengers out
of jail while all of this is going on dr
steven strange who lost the fine motor
control in his hands after a car
accident seeks out the ancient one and
after her death becomes a master of the
mystic arts he stops an invasion by
dermammu a demonic force from the dark
dimension by using the time stone to die
over and over again until the cosmic
villain gets annoyed enough to leave the
earth alone meanwhile the guardians of
the galaxy encounter and subsequently
kill ego before he can manipulate peter
quill into aiding his conquest of the
entire galaxy
in the absence of the avengers tony
stark begins to mentor peter parker as
spider-man peter tries to deal with the
evil arms dealer known as the vulture
aka adrian toombs who turns out to be
his homecoming date's dad the vulture is
defeated arrested and sent to prison but
not before he and several of peter's
classmates figure out spider-man's real
identity also tony stark finally
proposes to pepper potts lest you think
peter is the only super-powered teenager
in the mcu over in new orleans teenagers
tandy bowen and tyrone johnson acquire
powers of light and darkness and become
the vigilantes cloak and dagger
meanwhile on the west coast privileged
teenager alex wilder and his friends
learn their parents are all super
villains who control a powerful criminal
organization called the pride
the kids go on the run learn many of
them have superpowers or connections to
advanced technology and even run afoul
of dangerous artifacts like the darkhold
sadly it looks like peter won't be
meeting any of these young heroes as
their worlds are only slightly connected
to the mcu in asgard thor returns from
two years of looking for infinity stones
in various realms to discover loki's
deception when they find the real odin
he's at the end of his life and his
death allows hella to escape her
millennia of imprisonment she destroys
mjolnir blasts the two brothers into
space and takes over asgard thor winds
up on sakhar where he recruits hulk and
valkyrie for a mission to overthrow hela
which goes about as well as it can for a
plan that ends with the complete
destruction of asgard via fire giant in
wakanda t'challa's rule is challenged by
his cousin eric who teams up with evil
arms dealer ulysses claw and then
betrays him in order to gain favor with
wakandans who know claw as a vibranium
smuggler after being presumed dead
t'challa returns and aided by nakia
okoye and shuri regains control of his
country
after six years of waiting around thanos
decides to personally seek out the
infinity stones and the results are
devastating he kills loki and nearly
obliterates the last surviving
asgardians and an invasion of earth
leads to things getting so desperate
that the whole avengers crew except
hawkeye and ant-man who are under house
arrest for violating the sokovia accords
need to get back together to sort it out
they don't do so well despite fighting
on two fronts with one small team in
space and a massive force on earth
thanos gathers the stones snaps his
fingers and kills half the life forms in
the universe dissolving them into dust
before he dissolves nick fury uses the
space pager to alert captain marvel that
earth needs her help a month later
captain marvel and the surviving
avengers track thanos down in space only
to find out that he's destroyed the
stones and with them any chance of
bringing back the dead half of the
universe thor beheads thanos and the
avengers return home weirdly enough all
of this happens while ant-man is
involved in a relatively low stakes
heist movie when the snap happens though
he's left stranded in the quantum realm
while he's there five years go by during
which the heroes deal with the horrific
trauma in various mostly unhealthy ways
notably tony stark and pepper potts have
a daughter named morgan banner merges
his brain with the hulk while thor and
valkyrie found new asgard in norway
hawkeye loses his entire family in the
snap causing him to go rogue adopting a
new hairstyle and anti-hero identity as
the merciless ronin who hunts down and
ruthlessly kills criminals around the
world one of these criminals is william
lopez the father of fighting prodigy
maya after seeing her dad die maya
swears vengeance on ronan not knowing
that her dad's boss kingpin wanted
william dead after ant-man returns from
the quantum realm where for him only a
few hours have passed the heroes
realized that the solution to the
problem is of course time travel with
the help of iron man and the now smart
hulk the heroes travel back to various
key points in the timeline including
1970 2012 and 2014 to gather up the
infinity stones of those eras along with
mjolnir circa 2013 they also
inadvertently bring the thanos of 2014
forward to 2023 along with all of his
minions fortunately the hulk uses a
rebuilt infinity gauntlet to wish
everyone back to life and virtually
every hero in the entire mcu takes
thanos on at once the final blow is
dealt by iron man who dies on the
battlefield after gathering for a
funeral steve rogers hops into the time
stream to return everything to where it
should be returning after living a full
life with peggy carter in an alternate
past to bequeath his shield to sam
wilson naming him the new captain
america
outside of the mainstream mcu the
version of loki that the avengers freed
from an alternate 2012 in avengers end
game ends up in the gobi desert where he
immediately begins fulfilling his
glorious purpose by trying to conquer
the world again instead he gets picked
up by the time variants authority or tva
a time police force tasked with hunting
down rogue variants like loki and
destroying alternate timelines before
they can branch out too far from their
sacred timeline loki gets paired with
mobius a sympathetic tva agent who
recruits the trickster god into the
agency to help find their latest target
another loki variant this isn't about
you
this variant turns out to be a female
version of loki called sylvie who
restarts the multiverse allowing a bunch
of rogue timelines to emerge from
history loki teams up with sylvie and
discovers the tva is made up of variants
forcibly recruited into the organization
to prune rogue timelines and prevent
really evil versions of the tva's
mysterious leader from destroying
everything while offered a chance to let
this deception persist sylvie instead
murders the mastermind letting the
multiverse run wild while this may lead
to the destruction of reality it makes
one cosmic being's life more interesting
the godlike voyer the watcher observes
realities in which peggy carter receives
the super soldier serum doctor strange
destroys his universe and thor becomes a
party animal
ultimately the watcher is forced to
evolve from observer to doer when a
variant ultron threatens to destroy all
sentient life in the multiverse
assembling his own guardians of the
multiverse team the watcher manipulates
events so the alternate realities can
continue to co-exist
in the mainstream mcu the effects of
hulk's reverse snap are being felt on
both the cosmic and street level people
like yelena balova and monica rambo snap
back to existence only to discover that
five years have passed and their loved
ones are now gone re-establishing their
lives proves difficult since different
people live in their homes and billions
are still legally dead while support
networks form entire nations are also
forcing out recent immigrants due to the
sudden rise in population believing life
was better during the blip when half of
all life was gone some people react to
these changes violently anarchist carly
morgenthau forms a terrorist group the
flag smashers to attack governments
threatening her one world vision and
even augments her team with a new
version of the super soldier serum this
puts her in the sights of sam wilson who
rejects steve rogers request that he
become the new captain america after
working with bucky barnes and seeing how
steve's legacy can be tarnished by
unworthy successors like the dangerously
unhinged john walker sam takes on the
mantle of captain america and stops the
flag smashers the sudden rise in
sentient life on earth also jump starts
the emergence which threatens to destroy
the entire planet when a new celestial
is born alerted by the cosmic event and
a few remaining deviants the eternals
reunite where before they have always
stood by and allowed planets to be
destroyed a few now have enough love for
humanity to try and save the earth
cersei draws enough power from her
teammates to halt the birth of the
celestial tiamat and the celestial
aeroshem uses the eternal's memories to
determine if earth should be spared
while all this is going on one rogue
avenger is unknowingly creating her own
brand of chaos in the small town of west
view new jersey unable to cope with the
loss of vision who thanos kills by
ripping the mind stone out of his head
wanda maximoff manifests powerful
reality warping abilities drawing from
her childhood love of american sitcoms
wanda warps westview into an idyllic
town where she lives a suburban life
with a new version of vision she even
gives birth to twin boys who quickly
mature in a single episode to maintain
this illusion wanda inadvertently mind
controls the real-life citizens of
westview into becoming her personal
puppets her activities attract the
attention of the new intelligence
agency's sword and agatha harkness while
wanda eventually comes to her senses and
tries to free west view agatha goads
wanda into a battle wanda comes out on
top however and although she has to
sacrifice her happy life with her
husband and children she embraces her
new role as the scarlet witch she also
takes agatha's darkhold and starts
studying it leading to some major
problems very soon former assassin
turned car valet xiang chi currently
going by sean learns his father is
gunning for him when 10 rings agents
steal the jade pendant his mother left
him teaming up with his sister chang-chi
finally addresses his issues with his
father stopping win woo from unleashing
the soul-sucking monster known as
dweller in darkness on the world before
dying to save his son winwoo grants
shangqi the ten rings which begins
sending signals out into the universe in
europe peter parker attempts to have a
vacation free of spider-man
unfortunately this becomes impossible
when nick fury actually the
shape-shifting skrull taylos who is
covering for fury while he's on vacation
in space recruits spider-man to help
mysterio a man claiming to be from an
alternate universe to save the world
from dangerous elemental beings except
it's all a lie mysterio is just quentin
beck a disgruntled ex-stark employee who
uses peter to get his hands on a pair of
stark tech sunglasses that can control
an army of weaponized drones
spider-man gets the drop on mysterio's
illusions to keep him from killing
thousands of people but in a final act
of spite mysterio exposes peter's secret
identity to the world
with his secret identity now exposed
peter turns to doctor strange hoping the
sorcerer can snap his fingers and wish
his problems away instead strange offers
to cast a spell to make the world forget
peter parker is spider-man it seems like
an ideal solution until peter keeps
asking strange to rewrite the spell
creating multiple fractures in the
multiverse and drawing in people who
know peter parker is spider-man soon
spider-man villains from different
cinematic universes including dr octopus
sandman the lizard and electro begin
slipping into the mcu however the worst
new arrival is the green goblin who
kills peter's aunt may distraught peter
receives help from an unexpected source
two multiverse peter parkers who look a
lot like andrew garfield and toby
maguire together the spider-man concoct
some creative cures for their enemies
and de-power their shared rogues gallery
but just as things seem to be looking up
the multiverse begins to fracture peter
does the responsible thing by asking
strange to make the whole world forget
peter parker and prevent the villains
from coming through this essentially
makes peter a non-entity in the mcu cuts
him off from his support network of
heroes and friends and sets him up for a
brand new trilogy of solo spider-man
films however not all heroes need to be
alone for the holidays after a now 22
year old kate bishop crashes an
underground new york auction and steals
clint barton's former ronin outfit she
draws a lot of unwanted and potentially
lethal attention to herself from the
tracksuit mafia and kingpin fortunately
hawkeye is in town with his family to
see the embarrassingly catchy rogers the
musical initially hoping to retrieve his
ronin suit and keep kate out of trouble
clint ends up mentoring kate as they go
up against maya lopez aka ekko yelena
bilova and kingpin after bonding with
clint over their shared trauma and
showing she's really good at shooting
people with trick arrows kate looks like
she'll be taking over the mantle of
hawkeye and joining the mcu's
ever-expanding roster of new superheroes
every universe meets its end one day but
right now the marvel cinematic universe
is expanding faster than ever the
addition of tv shows on disney plus as
well as disney's acquisition of the
marvel properties that once belonged to
fox means that more characters are
entering the mcu than ever before in
addition marvel studios collaboration
with sony which owns the film rights to
spider-man and many spider-man related
characters means the universe is more
open to outside visitors than ever
before from the previous sony spider-man
to the tom hardy version of venom on
disney plus fans will soon be treated to
the arrivals of moon knight ms marvel
she-hulk echo and a secret invasion of
skrulls on the big screen a multiverse
of madness is preparing to burst open
also on the big screen we'll see the
further adventures of dane whitman aka
the black knight the return of blade and
an exciting sequel in the third ant-man
and the wasp adventure which will
feature kang the conqueror a menacing
variant of the character you may know as
he who remains a black panther sequel
will broaden the world of wakanda and a
fourth thor movie will prove jane foster
worthy of wielding the hammer and in the
more distant future we'll certainly see
the arrival of the fantastic four the
x-men and who knows what else the mcu
timeline is an ever-shifting thing but
when it comes to the first 15 years or
so you can now consider yourself fully
caught up cool
cool so cool
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]